Speaker 1: Let's go next to Joshua from
Portugal, one of my favorite countries
in Western Europe. Joshua from
Portugal, welcome to the program.
What's on your mind today.
Speaker 6: And the other
to be back after a long time?
Speaker 1: It's a pleasure to be back.
Welcome. I was.
Speaker 6: Just. Sorry.
Speaker 1: No, I was just welcoming you.
Speaker 6: I think I was just asking like,
it's kind of it's more like these recent days I'm
looking more and more like in American politics
and I'm looking outside as a European, of course.
And I always like baffled, confused and just sad
about everything that's going on. And compared
to how Europe's going, I feel like worried for
some of my friends who live in the States.
Speaker 1: What specifically worries you?
Speaker 6: School shooting, the rise of
the far right far right such as and violent
like MAGA, the Proud Boys and all that jazz.
It's so worrisome because it's so easy to
just fix some of these issues. Well, coming
from a European like gun school shootings,
for example. Yes. Like the recent school
shooting that happened in Florida a few days ago.
It's kind of sad that I I'm going to be
honest. I'm always going to have mental doubt
about it because of how it's a constant thing.
Speaker 1: It's hard, you know, listen, it's
hard not to get desensitized to anything that's
happening constantly, because one of the things
humans do is we adapt. And I am I agree with you.
I am aware myself of becoming desensitized to a
lot of the insane things that are going on. And to
some degree, it happens with the shootings, too.
Joshua. All right. Joshua's gone. We could have
delved more into it, but we lost Joshua. Let's
continue here. Why don't we go next to Ike from
Lagos? Ike from Lagos. Welcome to the program.
Ike, are you with us here, sir?
Ike from Lagos. Welcome. IK You probably
have the the wrong audio device selected,
so let's see if you could fix it, because I
would love to speak to somebody from Lagos,
but it's not clear if it's
going to work for us today.
Ah, right. And a failure with Ike from Lagos.
Let's go to. I'm not familiar with this name.
Is it Huon Fir from Portland?
Speaker 7:
Hey, David.
Speaker 1: Hi.
Speaker 7: Yes. I live in Portland, Oregon. I'm
a I'm an immigrant from Quito, Ecuador. And I
love that you have a Spanish as a YouTube channel.
Speaker 1: Thank you. Yeah, we are a we are doing
everything we can with it. I know some people are
continuing to insist that really I should be doing
the clips in Spanish. I just don't have the time.
But I did record a beautiful message in Spanish,
which we will soon be publishing on
the channel, explaining all of it.
But I think the channel is coming along nicely.
Speaker 7: So, you know, coming in into the U.S.,
I have to learn about the the political climate
here, because in South America, every politician,
every bad politician, every every career
politician is from the left. So we have people
like Rafael Correa and Petro and Maduro, which
are really corrupt and are making their countries
illegal. You cannot live there anymore. The good
salary in in Venezuela and sorry, the salary in
Venezuela is equivalent to $4 a month.
Speaker 1: Yes, I'm aware of that. Now,
the purchasing power is, of course, different.
Speaker 7:
Yeah. So I really would like to thank you because
you have helped shape my political opinion
of a power that the left is is helping everybody
in this country. And and the ride. The Republicans
are trying to stop everything of value.
Speaker 1: I appreciate that. I am doing
what I can to the extent that I am able, but
it's going to take a lot more than just me,
that's for sure. So we've got to keep building
the movement and getting people involved,
I think is the critical part.
Speaker 7:
Yeah. Well, thank you for taking my call.
Speaker 1: All right. Thank you very much. Great
to hear from folks from all over the world and
all over the country. We're going to take a quick
break, but I am taking more calls right after
this short break. So if you're waiting to talk
to me and you've got a few more minutes, just hang
on. We'll go right back to the phones in a moment.